and the few people would like to
pronounce that we're doing allergy right
every time I'm introduced they
destroy that word uh so I'll be walking
around but I know that I've got a
microphone I'm happy to project a little
bit more but I think it's gonna be good
uh today is going to be very Hands-On so
I provided a collab notebook for you
that runs and that you're going to be
writing some code in there as well uh
make sure I hope you enjoy it remove
some of the solutions but I hope I did
uh anyway even if not it's a good
fantasy hopping for that
um
we're going to start off with very basic
things just to make sure that we're kind
of about the same level talking about
like five Source going over the hood and
how they could actually does similar
calculations with numpy uh it does and
but by the end we're going to quickly
wrap up so we start off with like basic
high torch commands uh we'll do like a
linear regression on there and then
we'll talk about transfer learning doing
your own computer vision models and then
if we have time which I believe we
should
um we'll actually go into style transfer
it's a little bit of fun all the code
here is executable you don't need to
modify anything but one of the nice
things about it is that you can upload
your own images and do things that you
would want to do as well to make it a
little more personal to you
that said my style is very freeform I'll
be chatting I'll be walking around but
if you have a question feel free to
interrupt me at any time and then we can
actually just enter it on the Fly that's
kind of like the way I prefer to go
things uh I think there's a couple of
people who have just walked in just to
be our hello just to be uh to be running
everybody this website here will take
you to this collab notebook here
all right so show hands how many of you
have actually voted in five courts
before
that's one two three four okay perfect
this is the right final audience that we
have uh this is meant to be an
introduction to it we're now talking
about more complex things in pi torch uh
this is just meant to be a tutorial on
how to actually start working in high
courts I'm sorry I don't tend to do that
and I'm going to take this off because I
can project my voice you guys doing well
yeah all right good this is
a little weird to hear myself in an echo
uh so sorry yep I think if you don't
hear the Microsoft
oh good sorry
all right so all right I'm gonna have to
hear myself and once in a while we're
gonna have to hear
a little bit of backing on my phone
yeah
it's very very true
there we go okay
all right don't forget me up
uh all right so I forgot what I was
saying but we're going to start with
some very fun things hi George I know
that there was about four or five of you
here who would raise your handsome that
they worked with pi coach before uh one
of the first things we need to do is
first connect to our runtime so it
should already automatically be
connected to a GPU but if you go to
runtime here on the top click where it
says change runtime type you should see
GPU connected if it is not select GPU
we're not going to be working with tpus
just because
the graphics card underneath like under
liquid is actually in the GPU
then we can just connect to it
or you can do that by actually
running a very first line of code
so we're going to start off with just
kind of the simple stuff the usual
flashbacks here's the stuff that we
really care about
this section right here this is Oracle
we import uh Pi torch so we're actually
going to import sports but we could also
do some aliasing as well so this is
their neural net package this is their
Auto grad or their gradient descent like
backwards differentiation so this is
what we're going to be using for our
neural networks
we can Define custom functions here
we've got data sets and data loaders
that we're going to be using for our our
connection so if you're trying to get to
this code level it's right there
uh and then we've got some torch Vision
stuff things for the computer vision
models that we're going to be running
and then this torque summer is actually
quite simple nice little synopsis that
tells you actually how big your model is
and how much memory it should take up
and how many parameters you have coming
into the training wall it's a nice
little thing in there the rest is just
things that you should have seen before
and if not I'm happy to explain anything
there so we'll run the very first line
this is just going to import all of our
files
now if you did this correctly
this should say device type tuna when I
run this line so if I'm just going to
hit the device
and you should see device type Cuda
index00. so Cuda is the basically the
equivalent of the x86 architecture or
GPU so you'll see references to Google a
lot not as the same as using the Intel
x86 architecture it's just now on the
GPU side
everything we're going to need for
today's tutorial is all in this download
app so we're just going to run this line
and you'll see that this is going to
populate our left hand side with a whole
bunch of new files but uh you feel free
to look through them there's just
pictures and images and things for the
conference
but it takes up a second
and then you'll see the left hand side
will populate with all of the things
that we're going to be running once in a
while or as of for you guys have been
familiar with with collab you'll get
disconnected from your runtime after a
certain amount of inactivity
just rerun like relum sorry rerun the
first couple of lines here
and then go straight to whatever section
we're in at the very top of that section
and then you'll be fine so the sections
are meant to be sort of modular you
don't have to worry about running the
entire code to get to where you're at
they're pretty modular there all right
so sections here basically we've got
kind of high torch just neural Nets uh
image recognition and transfer learning
and then CNN from scratch and then the
sofa supplies where they cut through it
so if you're if we if you get
disconnected and we're in the neural and
stuff you would just go click here and
run those lines from there you don't
have to worry about running this a
problem of it
all right
we're all good we've all got our code
running you should see now a couple of
different files on there that you don't
faster than this than models they're all
good cool
okay uh there is a larger version of
this High course tutorial so this is a
via Bridge version of the end of the
class I'm happy to send you the one that
has a little bit more stuff it's got
some stuff on um
on natural Network processing and uh
um
but
okay
so
for one of the first things we need to
talk about when we talk about Pi torch
is what well what is a tensor because we
may all be familiar with an image or an
image is a tensor so if you think of a
grumpy cat here Grumpy Cat here we'll
look at it on the screen it looks like
one you know two-day image but really
it's comprised of three different
matrices
those three matrices stacked across each
other get a few percent image but that
if so a matrix is a 2d tensor a color
image is a 3D tensor
and basically you can think of tensors
as the generalization of matrices
and you can have for example a movie
would be a 40 tensor because you've got
images that change in time so that gives
you that extra Dimension
uh so what you see here is that they
tell you how each much of these so for
example for an RGB image it tells you
how much of the image is activated in
the Run Spectrum the green spectrum and
then that sort of kind of
uh overlaid on top of each other during
the state which I would like
the spinal is breaking off yeah that's
crazy uh so here's kind of like some uh
these are all tensors right I'm gonna
use that word very very generally here
so you've got a vector this is the 1D
tensor you've got a matrix or two
Defensor here is that image of broken
cut that we saw there that is a 3D
tensor here's a here's an image of five
intense 40 temperature and then here's a
5A sensor which could be a series of
right that would really be but then
obviously you can generalize this to how
many dimensions you want but they kind
of analogy breaks down uh pretty quickly
after five years and I don't know how
many applications where you need more
than it might be done
now very similar to numpy
tensors have a type
so you can do uh you can do torch that
float32 which would be a float tensor so
there are two you always see two
different versions of it so you'll see
this column here and that column there
the very first column or the CPU Center
is what happens when you're not
connected to a GPU you can still use
pytorch on compute uh pytorch on compute
will just give you a float tensor if you
were on the GPU you'll have torch.cudo
dot whatever that thing is so this is
quite pretty important because there are
going to be times where you're going to
want to run your model on a CPU for a
quick inference but look for training
you might want to do it on upload so you
got to make sure that you're actually
keeping track of the correct database
bye
yep one of the very first things that we
need to do here is actually
just see kind of how it works right so
we're going to be we've already
connected to our runtime we should
already be connected here so we can
actually create random tensors just like
we can in nullified so this is going to
be a very good parallel to like why GP
why Pi switch is so important is because
it allows us to do nump highlight
calculations on the GPS so there's a lot
of parallels because of it so if we run
here we could actually create our numpy
array and here's our torch random array
so you'll notice that it always tends to
start with the tensor at the very very
top here you notice that the known fire
rate is not this is a good good giveaway
that you're on
uh High torch and so is the defect now
here that this says float.64 and that
torch.64 because I did not need to put
this through the device here you
actually have to transfer things to the
GPU as you'll see later on for now for
now don't worry about that partner but
we could actually even check their D
types
and so we've got a torch sensor we've
got a numpy array so ND array here is
the equivalent of a tensor so an ND
array can be 1D 2D through D40 5D and it
is the exact same equivalent as a tensor
they just call it ND arrays instead of
using a more formal mathematical word
tensor which you do not need to memorize
uh so we can create 3D tensors in a very
similar way uh very uh exactly like
uh numpy when you do a 2d concert it's
the number of rows and the number of
columns in a 3D tensor it's the number
of matrices the number of rows the
number of columns so it kind of feels a
little weird
so you're going to see three four by
five matrices instead of five three by
four matrices which is what most people
think of when they do them I know I did
and I was like what's going on
okay
all right now we can
change
DMD type pretty easily we can create
things like supports.zeros if you could
imagine this is the same thing as a p
naught zeros it actually gives you a
matrix just for or tensor for lack of
reward uh
flow of zeros and then it's going to
have that specific detox so you can
actually change the effects on the Fly
you could change two times after the
fact you can change the types of upon
instantiation so here's a float where so
I guess it's still zeros but you notice
a decimal point here letting you know
that this is
foreign
here makes it everything all along with
it try blue
I kind of forgot if whatever one allows
for the operation to not lose any
efficiency so if you've got yeah
yeah I always forget
I just know that it does the right ones
all right okay so uh yep we can also
create explicit pensions so this would
be a tensor of
one row two columns two by three verbal
two comma three
and here we could also basically say
like I can create a specific main choice
and then obviously create its type so
here's the 10 circuits of the type
and uh there's also a couple of things
here that are a little bit novel for pi
torch this is this
uh this uh method applied to a tensor
that is a new underscore once and what
that does is that it says it says tell
me whatever Type X is create a new
Matrix or a new tensor of all ones of
explicitly this size but it takes it
inherits the D type of x
right which is I think something that is
not typically seen in that way so you
see here now I've got a fluid tensor I
noticed that I didn't have to explicitly
call it here X1 the float sensor but my
y here is automatically a float tensor
uh
there's a side method
just like a numpy
and we can add tensors in the usual way
obviously when you're adding fences they
have to be the same size
so there's several methods for adding
sensors and you'll see how wide this is
a little bit more useful as we get into
actual training models which is just a
very simplistic
version of it so we can actually take
our two tensors we can X and Y we add
them together there's also a torch.add
method where I post in the parameter so
let's say I'm going to torch.x comma y
and then another one which is the dot
add underscore method so I'm saying
to Y and X the underscore
in any of these methods means do it in
place very much like pandas uh like
Transformations within Place gets true
so if I do why not add notice here that
this is the value y originally was
supposed to be all one so when I come
here and I click on apply y-axis has
changed in place
it saves a little bit of writing but
it's very very common to see it in my
course in pipeworks code when you're
training things
foreign
second column and on
uh remember as you all just the python
complex you know the pythons are index
the level really hard on that
and we can reshape things as well so uh
here's a tensor that I'm describing so
I'm going to basically create random
tensor a 4x4 I'm going to change it with
this dot view this Dot View still exists
and still uh
oh
yeah still works never mind and I can
say x stop music 16 basically gives me
back one tensor of all size 16 or I can
do x dot U of negative one comma eight
which means gives me exactly eight
columns back as many rows as I need and
then they actually finally added reshape
as a method that you can call because
before there was no reshape method in
pipe torch so
um
code that would seem to look like it
would work would not uh but here you'll
actually see all three of those sizes so
we've got the original size of 4x4 that
I cast it to a one gain Vector uh here
then I change it to a matrix and I just
do the same time but basically the same
thing with two minus one so the minus
one so it's giving me as many columns as
I need as long as the number that
follows the divisible by the total
second so if I had to put a 7 here this
would not work
foreign
we can convert to and from PI torque to
numpy so we can say here's like hey
there's a torch once and then if I want
to change if I want to convert to numpy
there is an a DOT numpy method here
so I can just say well give me B and if
you notice here this one from being the
second tensor here to the housing
so this is no longer the same type
now
this is always a fun one to ask because
I get many different answers what do we
expect result A to B so we're going to
add a and I'm going to add 1 to it and
I'm going to do it in place and then I'm
going to print a and I'm going to print
B what do I think expect the result for
B to B
these are not because one's a numpyte
array one's a pi torch test
you can achieve in my let's run but
just curious what do you all think
because B going to be the same as a or
is it going to be a different way
they are the same B is a pointer to a
dot numpy it is not a point or two it's
not a new place in memory if I wanted to
do a copy then it would be different but
unfortunately fortunately or fortunately
like a you have to understand what's
happening on the hood here when you
change between numpy and
and Pie torch you may want to if you
want to do transformations to it outside
of it that doesn't want to that won't
interfere with the actual tensor itself
make sure that you use a copy method
because it is a pointer to a DOT num Pi
it is not a specific point in memory
with the value one in it
so this is a very common
confusing thing in file
is that because
uh if I understood correctly so
basically B is a pointer to a and then
it says call a.number
but I mean if if it's basically giving
you practicing things it's paid out them
by just giving you back the reference
too
you can umpire worry that's already
inside the country
I believe what you're saying is true I'm
not sure at the very very last part but
generally I think we've been just
divided
uh I think they're different D types so
the pie torch is a kind of its own thing
you can call methods to put things to
numpy and vice versa you can put things
to torch
um but I think they're in memory they
look at different elements but generally
I think the the gist of what you're
saying is still true though
right we can convert uh from numpy to Pi
torch so we obviously we saw that
there's a DOT numpy method to convert to
numpy we can convert from
numpy to torch pretty easily saying for
stop from numpy it's a little bit
different of a call but
same thing you'll always notice here
that the tensors don't give you as many
decimal points as one pyrite that's just
for printing
nothing so they literally are the same
other building
show the same number of decimals
all right any questions
trust me we'll speed this up very
quickly this will get a lot harder uh
but I do want to talk about a little bit
about why pytorch is uh well and this is
not just through a package whether it's
through uh tensorflow uh it's the auto
grad the automatic gradient set so that
this actually does all those derivatives
for you behind the scenes and this is
one of the reasons why it's so pretty
cool uh so if I'm going to Define I'm
going to do this mathematical operation
and I'll actually show you
the math behind it as well if you do not
understand calculus do not worry about
it it's just to let you know that what
we expect to happen does happen behind
the scenes and all of it is done with
one command so we're going to create a
tensor here of just number one
everywhere
and I'm just going to do some operations
to it so I'm going to have my X my
independent variable here's my dependent
variable y it's going to depend on X
this is very similar to how you're going
through a neural network or actually for
every layer of the neural net you're
being passed through some function so
you are the independent variable if
you're on the very far left of the
neural net you're definitely a dependent
variable or a complex value dependent
valuable as you're going through that
neural net
so imagine this is the very first thing
in doing that neural light we do three X
plus seven
that we do that all good going to give
us the same result area Square all 10.
so then because we created
uh by the way this requires graduate
true is only true for there's only for
this example
um
typically when we're working with neural
Nets this is automatically happen when
we sign the scenes you don't need this
this is just for this toy example here
so because y was created under the
result of an operation it now has a
gradient function method
so this gradient function method is an
add backward method this could actually
be multiplication or Refinery soil
whatever actual mathematical operation
we called on it and this is actually of
course tracking that automatically
now I'm going to do more stuff to it I'm
going to say well now Z is uh 2y squared
and then I'm going to take the mean of Z
and see what those values are you can
see that we basically get 200 because
the mean of all these formulas is also
200.
now we're going to do this by hand right
so if I were to take this derivative by
hand we could actually just do the chain
rule from calculus one one fourth one
quarter of Z gives us a I think this is
supposed to be one quarter here
not another two the two y squared
cancels it out so one half three so
seven we take that derivative we apply
it at x equals one we get 30 back
now for us all I need to do is do w dot
backward
so it says take this thing here
and go backward through all of its
operations as you're doing backward
gradient of this event or backward
propagation through a neural net and you
notice here that I get 30 which is
exactly the number there
so this means that we don't have to
worry about tracking the derivative of
in a very convoluted neural net with
possibly hundreds of layers or thousands
of connections it's pretty
straightforward to just do that and know
that it's all being tracked behind the
scenes with the exception of you
defining a custom function
so if you're doing for example
physics derived or physics that they
have
physics derived like machine learning
models where you need to have a function
to model some sort of physical phenomena
then you would actually need whatever
that derivative is but you can actually
do that later
said you can say here would be the
backwards
all right so now let's actually work on
a like a real piece of an example of
this actually going through this all
together so this is going to be mimic a
lot of what we're going to be seeing in
a neural net model so we're going to
start with a linear regression example
something I think we should hopefully
all be familiar with especially for
those who work in machine learning or
enthusiasts of machine learning so we're
going to have a thousand points here
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a bunch of random numbers and
then I'm going to give it a bias right
so we'll go to an offset here and then I
want to be able to fit this data as
close as possible using my high torch
method right so if we were to be doing
this in
sklearn or SMS leave OS stats model
um we can do this very simply but this
is showing you that whatever we can do
in there can we can also the pie torch
so what we're going to do is saying well
what does this uh
data look like and how do we equip this
data so I'm going to leave here's the
model I'm basically going to try them so
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
mimic 2x plus 3 here so this is this
sorry 3x plus 2 yeah so three times
these values plus two times this values
is going to be the data that I have that
data is going to be randomly generated
so it's going to be noisy and then I'm
going to try to find line of us fit
through it
so here is my thing for those that don't
know at is the equivalent of matrix
multiplication in pythons you can do
torch.net mole m-a-t-m-u-l but it was so
much easier to write an answer
all right
now here's what our data looks like so
this is all my noisy data clearly
there's a trend going upward upward what
I'm trying to Define is that what is the
line that best goes through this data
while minimizing the error which is
exactly what we're trying to do in a
neural net we've got a optimization
function we're trying to minimize this
error and we're going to do so via
backwards
so I need to Define what my
my optimization function is here for
linear regression we're going to use the
mean squared error and all that is is
just basically trying to minimize the
difference between my predicted value
then my real value squared and negative
very simple mathematical operation here
now I need to give it some sort of
initialization so whenever we start uh
training a neural net model we need to
instantiate the weights because the
weights are going to be randomly defined
but we need to define those ahead of
time I'm going to basically say my
guests or my very first thing I'm going
to do is just say I'm going to guess -1
1 instead of three comma two right
because obviously we don't know what the
answer is because they're coming to
oh sorry I need to Define averse
now I could actually show you what would
happen in that very first model so that
very very first instantiation by simply
saying this was my guess this class is
literally not bad how do we even
optimize what we're trying to do here so
that we can get the best model
so again this is just the thing that I
need to do because this is a toy example
but it has helped you illuminate what's
happening behind the scenes here I
actually need to create a parameter this
is a neural net parameter meaning that
this is a weight that I need to updates
they call them parameters right so when
we talk about when we see it in the in
the summary and when we start looking at
computer vision models It'll ask you
it'll say how many parameters does this
model have talking about waves
so
now if you notice
does here's my pencer requires graduates
too this is not letting me know that I
can track backward gradient set off of
here and now here is my actual training
step I'm going to
come in my y hats and my predicted value
of y is going to be my x times my
current value for my guess right so my
current parameter per k then I need to
calculate the floss
okay then I'm just doing some printing
here about that then I'm going to Lost
That backward this has lost that back
when we said where we said was exactly
how we do a backwards literally one line
of code perfect one line of code we
don't need to do anything else then we
need to change the values of the weight
so we do that with torch dot no gradient
so that means do not change the do not
change any value so you'll actually see
this throughout the code when we get
into the original model so I'm trying to
give you like a sweet synopsis over here
and we're saying do not upgrade any of
these ways so now go give me my a DOT
Gus subtract and remember the underscore
means in place my learning rate times
the gradient of that function this is
this canonical formula for updating
weights sometimes you'll see it with a
plus sign sometimes it's zero the minus
sign it just then changes whatever the
value of that learning so I'm doing it
here with the subtraction and then I
need to zero out that gradient because I
don't want it to be informed by a
previous step in my training when I'm
already in a new spot in my sort of
optimization while trying to find the
lower spot I don't want to be informed
by something that happened after I had
updated already so you will always have
to zero out your greens
and you'll see that one again I'll call
it out when we see it in the computer as
well
so here is our function
now here's my learning rate to find it
as point one and then I'm just going to
go through this thing a hundred times
and I'm going to you'll see that it
prints every time
all right you can see that we kind of
are stabilizing around here or around an
error of 0.11 doesn't seem to be getting
any better
it's perfectly fine and then I'm going
to do the parameter here you notice here
that I named this detached thing this is
just so that I can
plot it so this is just a one of those
things where
I need it for this
wow
we now use Pi torch to do linear
regression
see it's a little bit Overkill but
but uh you'd be surprised at how much
linear regression can actually work uh
now so one of the things that I'm going
to do very quickly like ah yep I'll put
it here I didn't want anything here I'm
gonna get this off
uh I know that you all have it just
remove it and then try to move again
without so the exercises for you all is
because uh solving the
uh solving
linear regression or basically the
method of B squares is a closed formula
meaning that there is a defined formula
for it to solve
um method Elite squares
these are all of our tensors defined in
our data
so the exercise for you was to actually
go in here delete that line that I had
accidentally left for you all uh but uh
I want you to write up the beta and see
how that compares to your actual guess
right so we're going to compare our
Theta
with our a DOT guess
and I'll give you guys a roughly five
minutes I'm not going to answer any
questions
here is the formula and here are two
ways that you can do an inverse and the
transpose is the two things you'll need
and then however else you want to go
about
foreign
you can do it in one line or you can
separate
your parentheses and the next one
and then do those all separately but if
this is a this can be done as one line
of code
and just kind of give me a thumbs up if
you've got it
okay
thank you guys all right
now all right
so for those who got it how much does
your value differ
much we're pretty pretty close to the
actual optimal as well
yeah
so if we wanted to coat this all in one
go
we'll have Theta is equal to
a torch
key next
mine's a little bit different you might
have different values
but
there you go you can do it in one Locker
so this kind of gives you a little bit
of knowledge of like the inner workings
of every single piece like how we've
been well maybe not this much so but
there are going to be times where you
need to multiply make sure it's just
together or tensors together so you can
use the at method
um but
we're sort of now going to be shifting
our gears into what the neural Nets are
right so how many of you are actually
are familiar or have worked with
neurolent in the past even if it has to
do with Pat George all right so good
good afternoon cool so I'll maybe go
through this a little bit more
quickly but this is just kind of level
setting on everyone like what is a
neural net and we'll start off with sort
of the layer perceptron which is the
very first thing this is kind of like
mimicking how a neuron works so if you
think of
um like a neuron in your brain it takes
an input
it takes all you know it synthesizes
that input and it gives you some sort of
output
now uh one of the funny things here is
that
this is linear regression this is a you
know a MX plus b
uh if you were to do it in the in the
algebra sense so basically what it's
saying is doing a linear position with
all of these different uh inputs and
just multiplying it by a weight but it's
just taking their sum so it's just
basically doing
the linear regression of all those
values so the the
supervisors
the
uh yeah the sum of all those values
there so now here you know when we think
about one sort of neuron
this is kind of like the model that
you'll see but we don't have when
they're on we've got many meaning what
we're trying to find out is how does
this then scale and what are the
implications of it are
so we can actually do that in
sorry I don't consider than your
compilation uh uh well I'll I'll get
back to this in a second I'll actually
jump here to the regular neural net
uh so what we're looking at here is that
well that model that we saw before was
literally just one perceptron so we'd
have these weights go to this one input
and then it'll do the linear combination
of those values and give you some sort
of output now what we're doing here is
saying well there's more than just this
one place where it needs to connect to
these data are being fed to actually a
whole bunch of different uh points in
the in the direct or in this case our
neural network so every single one of
these data points actually connects to
each one of these when those weights are
zero or not is dependent on the model so
one of the things that you're trying to
convert so
ultimately what we're trying to do is
take in our input and give some
predicted output back in the case of
classification models so in this case
you have binary classification we're
trying to find out what's the likelihood
that you're at this class and what's the
likelihood that you're that class and
we're going to be doing that via a very
convoluted
uh neural net
so for each one of these we need to then
say well how does this
input data affect the very first layer
then how does the
first layer then impact the second layer
again with weights so you're going to
see a whole bunch of indices here and
ultimately what we're trying to do
is be able to separate our classes very
much like we see here so if we have here
is our sort of our activation function
so we're going to go through all this
whole neural net at each point in our
neural net we have a non-linear function
that is actually activating it and it's
going to help us split this apart so if
we were to have this be our A1 and this
b or A2 in this case we would be able to
separate that data pretty easily could
also be done visually
but if it wasn't for the fact that this
activation function is non-linear
literally all women get back is lines
because if you were to go through and
work the math of every single one of
those weights hitting every single input
if there's no nonlinear activation it is
all linear combinations of those valves
you're just through a whole very nasty
algebra equation where you would have
one coefficient sorry one variable and a
bunch of coefficients that affect it and
those will all get added up so
if without nonlinear activation always
gives back is less so it is the fact
that the nonlinear activation function
is what makes neural Nets of what they
actually the magic that they can do
there's a paper written many many many
many years ago talking about how a deep
enough neural net with enough
data can can accurately mimic any
mathematical function
and as well
obviously depending on that function
depending on that thing that you're
trying to mimic may require more data
more compute than we actually have
resources for but we do know that this
actually can mimic any mathematical
function so this is why neural lessons
that we use so frequently
so for every single one of these points
in that neural net that I showed you
earlier
down there too
uh your what we're going to be doing is
we're going to compute the output values
so we're going to go through that whole
linear uh
we're going to go through the forward
propagation of that neural net so we're
going to start at the very far left with
our input values we're going to go to
every single layer multiply them on our
weights do our nonlinear activation
function go all the way to the end and
I'm going to say well did I predict the
class correctly yes or no
how off allies will calculate the error
in the True Value versus the predicted
value and then update those weights that
updating on the weights here is my new
weight should be my old weight plus the
change in gradient I remember before I
figured that subtraction it doesn't
matter which one you do it's just
changing the sign and I don't actually
need this part right here because I can
do the a DOT add underscore in another
as well so
so in a more General sense right here in
when we're talking about loss
last function we could typically do like
a mean squared error loss but here we
actually wanted to find that velocity
because whatever it is that we needed to
be whether it's a cross-centricy loss
Etc and then what you're trying to do is
find the point where the gradient of
that loss is zero or as close to zero as
you can get so that's where the minimum
of
your model is is realized and
then we hopefully output
and then we then go through here with
some learning rate parameter here so
that the previous equation didn't have a
learning way parameter but here's just a
learning rate so that you're not
possible oscillating around the actual
minimum you're actually trying to get
there in a way that you can do it so
pretty easily to work nicely
so now quickly let's run through a
linear equation model so sorry we're
going to run through our first very
neural net here this is going to be the
most complicated adding machine you've
ever seen before this is what I call my
Ruble cutting machine so what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
model we're going to say this is a
sequential and then you're not a neural
net it's going to have two inputs one
output bias equals false here is means
don't give it a bias layer it would just
give you zero anyway when you finally
update it for my Optimizer I'm going to
use my Autumn Optimizer it is a very
there's a more robust version It's the
category of the sense you can read all
about it in the documentation
and then for Criterion here is going to
be mean squared error loss right so
we're going to that's the loss we're
going to use we'll actually use
different ones as we work through our
examples today and then I'm just going
to print the model so what does this
actually look like
so
nothing fancy this will actually start
getting bigger and bigger as we go
through this so we're going to have a
linear model it's got two input features
one output feature that biases once
that's my model that's all I have
now what I'm going to do is in this step
here is we'll keep track of the total
loss I'm going to iterate through this
10 000 times
and then very first one is the progress
bar I need to do my data preparation
because a couple times happens outside
of the actual Loop or or depending on
what the model is that you're running so
I need to tell it well first Generate
random numbers you can formally on zero
to four that's what I'm doing there and
then I said well my data is my variable
and my target is the sum of those two so
I'm taking two numbers
and I'm outputting their sum and what I
would like to see is how long does it
take for my neural net to actually
determine what the output is
now we as humans should be able to do
this very quickly we four-year-olds can
do this depending on the size of the
data
uh and how smart they are so we're going
to feed forward this through our model
so we're going to take our output we're
going to put our data through our model
so that's going to give us our output
our loss is going to be our Criterion so
that's our means for their loss our
output versus our Target we're going to
have low this is just the loss for
tracking things we're going to do our
back propagation so we're going to zero
out our gradient we're going to do
livestock backward and then this
Optimizer dot step does the updating of
the weights for you
so
so this is the entire code for back
propagation menu right which is why it's
so nice
so let's go to this
should be very very quick
there we go let's plot this so all right
before you guys pop uh how many steps do
we think it'll take the computer to
learn
one plus one equals two
like a thousand steps four thousand
steps we did all the way to ten thousand
so
this is just like there's no right
answer here
it had to see 2 000 examples
for it to finally understand that two
plus two is four
so this is what I mean by
very very great if you've got compute
resources but it's this is why they take
so long to Train sometimes it does take
a while for it to do even something as
basic as
adding two numbers together and
determine whether some should be right I
do not need to show a four-year-old 2
000 examples
but I do need to show the states that
this this neural net which was very
simple by the way it was not anything
fancy uh
now here I'm just kind of showing you
like what that would look like so in a
typical case this is where you have your
training data this is where we don't
have training data you can think of it
as like okay does this
fit well with our with our validation
set but obviously I give a continuous
block chalk uh chunk and not anything
else out of there so but you'll actually
see what happens as we work through it
some more so this is the kind of the
diagram that I talked about so for each
of those steps it's basically saying
take my input progress through here do
my nonlinear activations check the
result is this like how good is the
result of the prediction versus the real
one and then do the backward propagation
updating every single one of those
weights that you see connected here by
lines all of those waves need to get
updated
and then I go through it again so I do
this step many many things
right
so this fee here is that activation
function so when you're going through
here you're basically doing uh the sum
of all of the weights times uh the
inputs the respective input of the data
this look should look like N X plus b
this is linear combination but this P
here is what the law is being nonlinear
and now most of the time we use things
like sigmoid functions or values these
are kind of the very common ones that
you'll see this is likely the most
common one you'll be using but there are
several different methods here that you
can see here
all right so for here now actually what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
that exact same model of the same
channel approach that we took before is
that instead of having a linear model so
I'm going to have my NN dot linear so
the sequential means that do do all
these steps in sequence
and then say okay my very first input is
two values my output is 20. so it goes
from 2 to 20 different lines uh or
different perceptrons then 20 into 20
but for every single one of those steps
I'm doing a sigmoid activation function
so it tells you here all the seven
layers or all of a sudden steps in in
there and then this is the exact same
code that I wrote before but instead
we're going to use a different model not
the one that we were written for so this
one is going to be our
um
model with non-linear activation it
takes a little bit lower because it's a
task to go through all those places and
update all those weights and when I run
this one here
I still actually needed it to run a
little bit longer right so before we
were actually waiting pretty close
around 2000 it took a little bit longer
but if you notice here it's because it
was trying to do some nonlinear
activation function so it was trying to
start curving out
as you're going through this instead of
finding the right thing so as you notice
here what this this uh
the sigmoid activation function where in
this case our nonlinear activation
functions like it's letting do things
that are outside of this line so if I
didn't have a nonlinear activation
function I would predict this line
perfectly like we saw before this
nonlinear activation function is
allowing you to do things outside where
I may have a
validation data or things that I'm
trying to do that are just generally
intrinsically non-linear
I'll skip this one because it's the same
thing over the revenue
now uh
when we typically train neural Nets we
want to
do several different versions of it we
don't always want to just like run it
once and say okay we found the minimum
because we have the problem of local
minimum versus global minimum
and so what we would typically do is say
if I had actually started say up here on
this red one and that was my very first
time I ran this model I'm going to
actually end up in this well here as
well as a local minimum not a global
minimum but the model won't see
everything otherwise so it'll be like oh
your model has reached you know its
Optimum point is going to stop training
it's going to ruin validation it's going
to probably hears your performance but
if I train several of these models at
once with different instantiations or
different randomizations of the wave I
may actually find this one which is the
equal one
this is a very common thing that you
would do you're running it on different
instantiations of those weights
all right
so now on to the more fun stuff so the
image recognition and transfer learning
so we I've shown you kind of like a
general schematic of what is in your
neural net looks like and that looks and
that's very similar that's very typical
for a neural net that doesn't have
convolutions
but whenever we're looking at images
we we need to we need to train the model
in a way that it actually understands
things about the geometry of it so for
example the wheels around
that you know humans have faces that
look like this in ours uh that got eyes
so what we do is actually well in a
convolutional neural net we actually
scan that image so we don't look at
things we don't take an entire image at
once we actually scan chunks of that
image
and this little patch here is meant to
be mimicking that so it's basically
going to be scanning this image and then
finding and then kind of taking
information off of it and updating those
weights and saying like you know does
this have a corner Etc and I'm
generalizing here I'm going to show you
kind of like how this actually plays out
but the composition is basically saying
like
give me the inputs of this and it's
going to multiply it times the input of
a convolution those inputs of that
convolution are going to be updated as
their trainings
um
but it's trying to scan this images
four shapes and things that will help it
recognize what that is
now that's what the the convolution does
is pooling or what's called Max pooling
you can think of it as a way to zoom in
on an image and look at things in
different levels of of scale right so if
I've got if I'm trying to do several
things in this image I'm trying to
recognize the fact that there's a car
there and also maybe a bird there uh the
car is going to be picking up a lot more
of that foreground versus that board's
going to be small so that Max balloon
helps me to zoom into areas where I can
then identify those other images
now it does this in many many different
steps ultimately you get to the last
layer which is going to be a flatten
layer so you basically go from a tensor
that is in some given shape to a vector
then you're going to do a fully
connected there this fully connected
layer is going to look very similar to
that neural net but we showed the
schematically before and then we're
going to do some sort of activation
function and get our predicted classes
now
we don't need to reinvent the wheel
every single time we go to the original
model
one of the things that we can do is that
we can leverage transfer learning and
transfer learning is very useful because
whenever you're working with images of
things in the real world meaning
you're trying to identify I don't know
Superman versus Batman
whatever it is they've been trying to do
here
if those things are things that have
been modeled in other in other models
for example like uh Google's imagenet
you can actually take some of those
parameters because it takes a very long
time for those parameters to actually
optimize so this is no longer true uh
and now you can train image that a lot
faster but image that took 14 days to
train
14 days continually Around the Clock
compute compute compute compute
I know that that analogy no longer holds
true today we can actually do it in a
couple hours now but we don't need to do
it in a couple hours we don't have to
and so this is actually from a paper
that is linked at the very bottom that
as you go through each of those layers
so what each convolution does is it
basically tells you like the very first
convolutional layer will identify lines
so like is there a line like this and
there's a line like that
second layer will then start identifying
lines touching those old trackers
and the third layer Etc will do more and
more so you'll actually get more complex
shapes so this layer three is really
deep into it with this layer three if
you notice
these honeycomb patterns
are actually being identified in this
actual real images
these are human faces
your faces we've got
ladybugs and things that are generally
red in shape so the Tomato we'll leave
this in the car here are wheels so it
starts to identify things that are
around to it it basically says how is
how they actually have images for almost
all the layers which is actually really
cool I only show player three here but
it's just it's basically showing you
look in each layer what section is
getting is getting highlighted by that
image so here this is this layer three
is like helping you identify shapes
so if you have similar things in your
training data you do not need to start
from scratch you can actually leverage
all this material so this is what
transfer learning does but transfer
learning does it says here is the base
model right so here is all of the
information about shapes what what a
frog looks like what a ladybug looks
like what a car looks like and then it's
drilling it in a way that will help
identify the 1000 classes that were in
image
now for your task or whatever task that
is you may not have a thousand classes
you may have two but you know that your
images contain information already
contained in here so I don't mean to
train this part by myself I'm going to
say give me all the weights from this
model and then change this last little
bit
for your specific purposes
yeah so is it possible in advance to
predict which layer will identify which
feature or is it or exactly icons Black
Box
I think it's model dependent like if you
change the architecture of the model
that layer that identifies something may
change
so that's why it's now always like layer
three would do this layer three and it
was method that the layer three and vgg
we do before they trade image
to identify I don't think so I think
it's on uh app like after the fact both
agreement
yeah apple story sorry
so what we're going to do and UL will
have the data in here so I've given this
talk at Pi data in Miami before and I
have to M from Miami
so we're going to detect or we're going
to use images of Cuban sandwiches
which you can all find here in Manhattan
there's also a very big Cuban and
Venezuelan popular as well so these are
the king and queen of the Miami food
scene
so we have a whole bunch of images in
one of these folders that has images
that I scraped from the internet of
Cuban sandwiches and stuff that I love
it we're going to see if we can train a
computer vision model
to do just that to identify the
different females too
so
I'm going to run this here just very
quickly so that we don't run out of so I
know my computer doesn't stop but I will
talk about this so this normalized thing
here this very very first line This is
the average and standard deviation of
every single Channel or of the three
channels of all the images in image map
right so when we're downloading this
data set that already exists we're going
to normalize to that so that we fit that
model a bit nicer so you'll typically
see this in computer vision
um
tutorials they'll be like oh we're going
to train using resnet and then they'll
use that because that data set has
already been trained you know exactly
what those values are so those are the
normalization values these do not come
from out of an air they come from the
data set that is in the the original
model We're translating from
so now
this dictionary here is our data
transforms so for our training set so
here's one of the challenges with
transfer learning that what we're
typically doing it on models that are
much much smaller than uh than the
original image that a red event or
whatever it was so I think they had
millions of images for all the different
classes so you had like 100 000 images
of bicycles 100 000 images of whatever
else is there we've got 300 images of
Cuban sandwiches and 300 images of
cupidos that's not a lot and this is
very true when you're doing typically
like small scale computerism
so if you're trying to
train
again
because if you don't do it it'll be fine
I can run it without that lying to see
if it doesn't really change a lot but as
you it's basically helping standardize
the images so it's because the
parameters are optimized for that for
that translation
so so the original trade model was
already normalized with those so all the
images in the original internet were
shifted and then trained on
oh I see so the parameters are optimized
to those parameters so that shift
so one of the challenges of having a
small amount of data for a computer
vision model is that it doesn't handle
variety very well so if all for example
have a friend of mine who did the model
on tried to identify women's shoes
uh and all the students were pointing to
the right like there was always just
like it was like an image of a shoe that
was not even if you've been wearing it
was every shoe was pointing around
and then as soon as you give them an
image over two point left you know that
I'm ready with this
so what we need to do is we actually
need to do those variety this is our way
for us to augment our data this is
literally what we're doing here we're
doing data augmentation so we're taking
in our transform so we're taking our
data we're going to resize it to the 224
by 224 which is the size of the original
images we're going to put it to the
tensor we're going to normalize it based
off of those transforms uh or do a
random half line so that's basically
looking at it like a like a top-down
kind of like a angle View and we're
going to do random horizontal flip so
that means that an area that is left to
right should be look like one that is
right to left right there's nothing
there we can do vertical flips
uh I don't think it's necessary but
there are a bunch of these
Transformations that you can do you can
add lighting you can darken images you
can
do a lot but you always have to be
careful of what it is that that image is
doing like for example do I want to
detect a cat that is upside down as a
cat or do I want that to be something
different do I want that to say like
give me this as a flag or something like
this not something that I should be
seeing naturally in the wild
so that's for you to do and decide which
Transformations you need so I do the
horizontal flip and fi transformation
just to give you like an angular View
and then for the validation set you
never want to touch that there's no
point in
augmenting your validation statements
that you're only wanting augment the
training data set so then here's where
these data sets lie
uh here's the validation data Supply and
then here is where we're actually going
to be loading the data so this is is our
data loaders we're going to do a batch
size of 32 we're going to shuffle that
means of every time it adjusts them in
it's going to shuffle those around so
that it's not doing it always in the
same order
because you can
basically give uh give information to
your model that will take it harder all
the images always
so then there we go
here is the fun stuff so we're going to
take our model so from models with an s
dot resident 50. so models with an S
comes from the apply torch package it's
going to have our 1950 this pre-train
gets true uh is what's needed is two
devices and now we're finally going to
be putting things on the GPU
and this line right here so for param in
model dot parameters for Ram requires
grad gets false that's me saying do not
update these weights
because I am literally transferring all
those parameters over and I don't want
to change those
what I do want to do is modify the fully
connected layer this you'll actually
need to check into the documentation of
like what is that final layer called
sometimes it's dot FC sometimes it's
fully connected whatever it is you need
to look at what that model parameter was
but for resonant 50 it's model.fc and
I'm saying change that one out to being
2048 to 1000 which is what it was before
and I'm saying we could take it from the
original 2048 that'll give me 128 extra
ones to do this Revenue activation in
place against true sounds very similar
to what you would need for uh pandas and
then you say okay then from that 128
give me my two options out
right giving my weather you think it's
in the netball what do you think it's a
cute sandwich
here is our cross entropy loss that's
how we're actually defined and defining
this and our model Optimizer is still
going to be our off model uh m
and here is that summary that I told you
about so you have to give it an impetus
like what does my image look like so my
image is three channels by 224 by 224
and if you notice here here are all the
parameters involved in every single one
of these
so this is how many weights it would
have so total parameters of resonant 50
is about roughly 24 million of which
we're only training 262 000.
the other 23.5 million
are frozen we are keeping the original
values they had in Resident 50. this is
what the transfer part of it is because
we're doing non-trainable stuff with
trainable stuff
uh
that model is about 300 megabytes in
size
uh almost 400 megawatts in size there we
go
and
and what we've got here we're going to
train our model so I'll try to talk to
this a little bit so the very first
start is just printing stuff
so you need to actually look at your
model in two different phases your model
is going to have a training phase and a
validation phase for every single uh
batch that you do for epic so if the
phase is trained set my model to train
this means this model without training
means my weights are now allowed to be
changed
if my model is not in trained it's in
validation I do model dot email this
model dot email freezes always
because you don't want your model to be
training on validation set and actually
updating those weights
because you're not supposed to be
updating those weights when you're
looking at validation data so this
model.email freezes all weeks so you'll
always typically see this just running
lost we're going to have our inputs and
our labels from our data loaders we're
going to put them through the device
we're going to run this on this on the
Pu our outputs are going to be our model
inputs our loss is going to do this so
this is again it's a very simple line
code
and then if we're in the training phase
did the background design so we're going
to do our last step backward lock Zero
Hour agreement through the backwards and
up the minor step there to basically
update on weights
and then this is just additional stuff
for tracking the errors
yeah all right we're going to run this
very quickly I only do three three
epochs here
uh so remember I had roughly 50 50 I had
roughly 300 of each so if my model were
to be guessing randomly it would get 50
on the right because it's a rum
so when we first do our first epoch
we get an accuracy of about Invisalign
validation by the way because an
accuracy about 78 our validation is also
across the expert 50 50.
to the point where after three training
rooms or three epochs we're starting to
see some really weird things happening
here our validation our loss accuracy a
little bit higher than our validation
accuracy validation accuracy seems to be
frozen in there but we could obviously
turn this a little bit more
so we have just ran our very first
transfer learning model
we can save that model
check those weights we can save it here
as our checkpoint you can change you can
change the you can save the weight by
itself or you can save the whole Pi
torch model obviously one's going to be
bigger than the other
so you can do this the state dictionary
and then here's where those words get
updated and then we can also load from a
previously trained model if that's what
you want to do so I've actually trained
this to be a little bit longer so I'm
going to do the same thing I'm going to
do my I have to Define my architecture
before I can load in a model I have to
have the architecture be the same so I
do the resnet 50. I don't need to
download the pre-train weights because
I'm going to give it weights
and then I need to change the
fully connected layer and now I'm going
to do model back load stay fixed and
then here are those weights that I need
to do and then model dot email so I
don't want to change
this will always print out
the model
for you
and then so here are some test images
that we saw and we want to see how well
we're performing on them so these are
all in our validation set
and we're basically going to be passing
it through and saying like what predict
what these are the softmax is going to
give me the percentage of the
probability that it thinks it is one of
each of those classes
and then lastly I'm going to show this
so here are
four images
in our training slot
and let's see how we performed this is
identified as a 66 likelihood of being
at EPA so great
this is a cumin sandwich 92 likelihood
this actually says the word Cuban but
it's not learning that it's learning all
of this stuff so listen 17 chance of
being a Cuban sandwich and this one's a
little bit harder this is almost 50 50
this is 52 48 this isn't it but I can
see how it can get confused as a human
heart to add another model to understand
if my images had a lot of text on it
then I could probably train things to
like identify text but like I'm boo out
of all the things that I had I think
there was other out of the 600 images I
think there's four head packs
they are yeah yeah
[Applause]
we could do something yeah but I would
say
[Music]
so
um so that's kind of like the primer on
transfer learning so like if you had
images that you wanted to download by
the way there's a way for you to like
Google Google images and then there's a
like a little code that you would write
in JavaScript that would download all
those images for you that's what I ended
up doing I forget that so it was but you
can easily search for it like download
all the images from Google image search
JavaScript
gives you a little snippet you type in
your thing you go to the console like
you go to the inspect on Chrome type in
JavaScript and download them all for you
that's what I needed uh I think it stops
at like 300. there's a wide app again
but it's a good way for you to think
about like things that you want to
identify and just play with it you've
got the entire architecture here you
just have to point into the folder where
it has a training set and your
validation set and however many classes
you want I chose two it could have been
ten it doesn't matter if you want to
identify I don't know all the Power
Rangers you can give one class for each
so now we are 20 minutes left and we've
got two paths that we can go and I want
you to choose which property go do we
stay more on like the CNN side and start
actually building convolutional neural
networks from scratch or do we move a
little bit more on the artistic side
when we actually talk about style
transfer and how that works and actually
work on our own sales transfer images
cell transfer would look like
if you're not sure what that word means
like that here's an image here is a
piece of Arc how do I get my original
image to be in that style
from scratch well let's take a look I
see that you're the one with motives
from scratch
one two three four
style transfer
it's not trying for Wednesday by the way
you have the code for both so
so there's nothing here that would be
that would be at a loss and I'm happy to
stay in answering the questions that you
might have
things but this is actually one of my
favorite things uh but it kind of feels
like
with Dolly and stable diffusion that
this is no longer necessary but this was
a step in order to get us there so as a
gentleman was asking earlier like how do
you know uh which which layer helps
identify certain things you do know it
after the fact so there is a paper here
by goddess at all
um that was looking at BGG 19 as a way
to identify like what are which of these
layers is helping identify physical
features
so things like is this like is this a
tire is this something uh you know
ladybug Etc versus what is this is the
artistic or the style of the image so
they did very similar things that we saw
in the previous one where you actually
see like how it gets activated in each
of the layers
so they're saying that
these three convolution one one two and
two one
I believe these three are the physical
ones this is the style one or if I got a
wrong answer three verses
but
so what they're actually doing is
something a little bit different because
there is no right answer so when we're
looking at typical cnns where we looked
at Echoes versus Cuban sandwiches or we
looked at resnet 50 with all 1000 images
like there was a right answer
this there is no right answer here this
is why it's called semi-supervised
you're looking at outputs and you're
saying this is good enough but there is
no true optimization minimum you're just
going to get to a point where you say
I'm happy with those results and you
stop
so what we're going to be able to do
here is well I always forget the name of
this artist here but obviously if I can
go Star tonight uh Edward which is
screen and we're with our guys
we can go through here and and create
our own images to be in a specific Style
so the bgd 19 we're actually not going
to care about is Alpha layers we're
going to download the model but unlike
you know we did before we froze weights
and we've like changed the fully
connected layer we're going to download
the model and look at only specific
layers and see how actually that all
works out so when we look at the vgg 19
which we're going to be down in just a
second there are going to be the
features which contains all the
convolution of cooling layers and then
the classifier which contains the three
fully connected layers at the end we
don't need to fully connect the layers
at the end because we're not trying to
identify anything so what we're going to
do is we're going to get the features
portion of it so we're going to get our
models pg-19 we do want the weights uh
yeah we don't want to wait I'll put the
features there and then we're going to
freeze those weights for some of the
adults we're only going to change
certain models of certain parameters
we're going to move this device this
over to the device so this is going to
be running on the GPU now this would
probably take about 10 times longer if
it was running on the CPU it doesn't FY
so if you don't have uh if you wanted to
run this on your laptop and you don't
have a GPU get ready to wait or you can
just use Google call it
so
here we're going to load in our images
so this is just how I like load in our
image it's just
uh
nothing's fancy going on here this is
still the same training on the same data
set which provided with normal revision
probably the same
all right so here is going to be my
image
that I want for my content and my style
so by the way I believe I gave you the
option to put in a URL yeah
so
the two reasons that I have these are in
my data folder
this is a picture of my dog
there's a picture of Day of the Dead
Style hey if you wanted to use a very
different thing all together and you
wanted to go to Google images and type
in Picasso
and go through this artwork
and say something
I don't know I'm gonna pick someone that
I find a little bit easier
uh uh so there's a very nice one here
that I like to use sometimes
where is it
the painting at the beach
uh yeah yeah it could be something like
this like
like you can use something like this
that has oceans in the background you
have things in the foreground that look
like snakes candles Etc
you can just right click on here
hit uh copy image address and put that
into that function that we had defined
earlier so instead of
instead of putting in this path here
you would put in well it's actually in
the picture of my dog if you want to do
it for the style you would put in that
URL there if you have a picture on your
laptop that you want to use for yourself
or your pad kit Etc
change that one there just upload it
literally take your picture and drag it
to this pane it'll automatically upload
all right
so now onto the
fun stuff that the actual techno puts so
we're going to put this layer out so
here we're going to actually
so you notice there's actually a lot of
stuff on here so we need to identify
from that original schematic that we
showed like which one of the actual
layers that are going to be need to be
modified and the ones that were actually
need to capture specifically so that's
how we would find it we would need to go
in here and find exactly which we need
but
they're already marked for you 1 6 11
2013 29 so this is the Bradley one one
two two three one four one three two and
five
so here's the one that does the content
representation all the rest of style
so I was wrong when I said the first
three were content so yeah let's figure
out which one had one this is the
content stuff this is the style
yep so how exactly this is from the
paper
so this is not something that I like I
had to go into the favorites like which
are the ones that they actually got and
did they explain how they determined it
or is it basically
they did I don't I don't recall I was
trying to just recreated without getting
too into the wings
all right so one of the first things
here is um this gram Matrix this gram
Matrix is actually
helps determine whether two things are
in the same style
so for us it's very easy to determine
when two pictures are off by literally
looking at a pixel pixel difference
right if we can do a pixel or pixel
difference we know if these images are
off it's very different for style how do
you know one thing is in the same style
as the other there is a mathematical
object colored brand new Matrix
kind of does this although it was
defined for something different before
it does work in a scenario and what it's
basically doing is taking
um
that Matrix and like multiplying reshape
or so we're getting each of the features
that
there's a matrix where it's our
basically doing anything about
The Matrix times itself is transposed
right and it's doing so in a way to then
determine whether or not that grand
Matrix has the same style of the
original right so we're going to be
doing this comparing it to the original
versus the
um
the target image right so we're trying
to say like how far is this brand Matrix
from the red Matrix of the style that
we're looking for and that's how we're
going to be comparing whether we're
getting closer to that style while also
keeping two different things we're going
to be keeping track of the style but we
also need to make sure that our pixels
aren't changing in a way that our cat
still looks like a cat a dog still looks
like a dog and you'll actually see that
in a bit when I actually go through the
example here I'm actually going to start
collecting prey playing through here so
you can see some of the
I'm going to explain it in just a second
but I do want to start running this
model so that by the time we're going to
explain the next you can see some
outputs
so we're working
so we need to get our content features
so we Define these functions already so
we've got our content features we're
going to get our content we're going to
get our style features here are going to
be our style grams right we're going to
do that random Matrix for our style
features for each of those
and we need to create this clone so
we're going to be making a copy of our
image and saying where are we right now
how does this compare to the original
Target and to the original Style
uh and then we need to be updating our
losses and our weights so this is
actually the part that is much more of
an art than a science so each of these
tell you how much to ident to adjust the
style so the very very first layer is
going to be things in the foreground so
the things in the foreground how like
how big of an impact do you want it to
have on an image then you can think of
these as like things receding into the
background so if you think of uh rename
a Greek
foreground is the snakes with the
candles
background is the ocean so how much of
those do we want to play a role in it so
this has been very much a trial and
error sort of thing
I chose these
once I think I modified them like
another time and I have never changed
them since
and then last thing what we need to do
is then have a competition between this
constant weight of a salad so this is
the alpha beta so in the actual paper
you see this ratio is what matters
um
and that's how you're going to be
updating the loss itself so we're going
to come to the loss of this by the way
is
the difference between pixels
so we want to make sure that to build to
ensure that this gets minimized is that
our
the pixel shapes really aren't changing
so when we see a corner that corner is
always still there if there is plenty of
white space then that's a space that
since all of those pixels are always
going to look the same doesn't matter if
it's local or as you as you scroll
through an image you're going to see
that there are in the edges that form
those edges still have to stay there
things that are part of the background
have a lot more space to then be filled
in by our artistic letters
all right
training steps
there's not a lot here difference this
is just kind of like the style way from
doing the grand Matrix and all that but
here again all we need to do is these
three things for our optimization
and I am going to start at the very top
so this is the very very first image
after starting not the original image if
you notice I'll try to zoom in here
notice all the swirlies here
this white space
is now going to be filled in by things
that are not that could be filled in by
style meaning that since it's a white
canvas or a canvas with not a lot of
pixel changes in terms of coloring uh
then that's where we're going to start
filling in a lot of those cool images
this ear here forms a border I can fill
in inside the ear I can fill out outside
the ear that border should always be
there
uh you'll start notice that there's
actually being painted on her head
there are things that are never going to
change you'll always see this lamp you
will always see this painting of a
Native American in your background uh
this carpet where she's laying on very
similar to white faces it is our start
filling in with some of those features
over the art style
but things like the nails are going to
always stay the same because they form
hard boundaries between changes and
letters
layers are higher for boundaries correct
we want to make sure that the content
stays the same
in the context that you see versus
texture correct
so as I scroll through here I'm going to
go through this a little bit quicker
you'll start to see that there's more
things being filled in and you'll see
that a lot of those patterns start
popping them out more
and if anyone is running this on a
different image or image of your own
that'd be really really see it's always
fun to see how much this is starting to
get filled in here now with the Roses
we'll actually show the the original end
and uh the original artwork as well and
you'll see where it takes its influence
from oh it's still right
okay that was just eight images out of
20 you can run this for as long as you
want I'm going to stop it
up
disabled
sorry no
I think I do not mistake oh
foreign
you'll see that the image of the dog
gets filled in with a lot of the
artistic elements of the Day of the Dead
and then the uh
ultimately the final one is going to be
different let me see if I have it over
here in my data
foreign
steps
so this is what my dog looks like now
with the Day of the Dead and I'm going
to show you what that original data did
looked like
here
so you'll see where my dog takes
inspiration from this
roses that are here uh
so you'll start to see things that might
pop out for you these earrings here
really look nicely on her nails
Guinness bits here I think come from
generally this area here and like all
the features in the white space here
so
yeah so this is fun
I know I just kind of feels a little
obsolete now that Dolly came out
but still kind of cool you can still do
this with pie torch now
so yeah I'm actually having to stay a
little bit after any questions they all
may have but I believe that's kind of
where I was going to leave before for
today's presentation
foreign
[Applause]